[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me fais un petit cadeau une petite
chronique les gens mais parce que
j'amène du Lot je vais vous parler de ce
livre qui vient de sortir de paraître en
français c'est 500 ans de résistance
autochtone par godeal ce livre existe
depuis plus de 20 ans il était sorti à
l'époque en partie enzyme mais après il
avait été réuni dans un volume dans un
livre et c'était un des livres qu'on
suggérait souvent dans les débuts noirs
pour pouvoir expliquer la colonisation
les problématiques de colonisation sur
l'île de la Grande Tortue et partout en
Amérique
après plusieurs demandes des requêtes de
l'avoir en français je me rappelle que
les gens dire il faudrait qu'on l'aille
en français puis maintenant il est là en
français et le livre est magnifique
c'est un objet de collection je le
recommande à transmettre si je peux pas
dire autrement est-ce que vous l'ayez
dans votre collection dans votre
bibliothèque et cependant il y a quand
même les quelques avertissements à
donner
c'est que ça parle de l'histoire
coloniale et ça leur parle d'une façon
qui est vraie qui est vécue aussi par du
côté des premiers peuples donc il va y
avoir comme dans l'histoire des passages
assez violents je pense beaucoup à au
début de la colonisation avec Jacques
Cartier excusez-moi avec Christophe
Colomb l'autre gars mais on parle des
fois de passage justement où on
reconnaît activement que les femmes
autochtones étaient mis en esclavage
pour être vendu comme des esclaves
sexuels et là on parle pas juste de fin
on parle de filles et de jeunes filles
donc
quand le lit il faut le lire vraiment
avec la lentille de ce qui était
l'histoire c'est-à-dire une Antille qui
nous protège des violences coloniales
parce que c'est très dur de voir comment
les femmes les filles les humains qui
sont au coeur de nos sociétés ont été vu
comme la chair à canon ou même
qu'il est prêt à être vendu en esclavage
et ça malheureusement ça fait partie de
cette vision là et souvent quand on
parle
de la fin du monde de l'Apocalypse je
dis même vous savez l'Apocalypse elle a
commencé en 1492 et on continue de la
combattre aujourd'hui donc c'est
important de voir ce livre là comme
étant
une lentille nécessaire à ce que l'on
voit aussi des luttes autochtones pas
comme dirait quelqu'un quand est-ce
qu'ils vont passer par dessus ça c'est
très dur de passer par dessus 500 ans de
colonisation mais c'est pour ça que 500
ans de résistance autochtone et bien sûr
maintenant qu'il y a eu le temps de
m'assurer aussi ce livre là vous allez
avoir un livre totalement différent de
celui qui était sorti dans les années
2010 c'est un livre je pense que c'est
un auteur aussi qui est passé entre les
mains des mouvements de femmes
autochtones parce que je trouve qu'il y
a vraiment un regard un peu plus
pas plus calme mais un petit peu plus
profond et un peu moins dans la colère
un peu plus dans le changement la
transformation d'ailleurs il va parler
des mouvements qui sont arrivés suite au
mobilisation j'aime bien montrer qu'un
petit passage pour la mouvance et toutes
les autres passages ensuite comme elle
s'y porte comme staning rock c'est
important de voir ça comme un livre qui
est en progression parce que à tous les
jours à toutes les années on voit une
transformation il y aurait sûrement
maintenant des chapitres pour Joyce et
chacuan on parle aussi des femmes
assassinées disparues c'est toutes des
approches qui à l'époque étaient pas
encore discuté par rapport justement à
la décolonisation des systèmes donc je
le recommande et si vous voulez vous
rajouter un autre petit volume pour
combiner ça avec une perspective du
Québec et bien je recommande de
l'acheter en même temps que c'est le
Québec qui est né dans mon pays
d'Emmanuel Dufour c'est une perle à
avoir avec une autre perle et ça ça va
tourner dans ma bibliothèque très
fièrement alors je vous souhaite une
belle semaine une bonne lecture
n'hésitez pas justement si vous avez des
livres que vous voudriez qu'on dont on
parle ou qu'on explore parce que souvent
ce sont ces bijoux là qui vont rentrer
dans les écoles qui vont entrer dans les
universités les cégep et qui vont aider
les jeunes à transformer leur vision de
ce que c'est être autochtone et ce qui
était la colonisation aussi avec ces
vérités et ça l'odeur mais aussi avec sa
résistance alors je souhaite une belle
semaine